on this opioid awareness and Fentanyl
drug and Prevention Day we take a look
at how those drugs impact expected
mothers Victoria Saha joins us in studio
with information on a program that helps
ease moms off them Victoria the CDC
reports the drug epidemic is growing in
the U.S especially among women when a
pregnant woman is using experts say it's
it not only poses as a direct threat to
the unborn baby but could also play a
huge influence on that baby to start
using drugs later in life a program at
Roseman University could stop that cycle
I hope she's okay Aaron migliera is due
in about a month she was using drugs
around the time she realized she was
pregnant I was honest with my OB GYN and
uh like from the first get-go and told
her I was on heroin the empowered
program at Roseman University helps
pregnant woman ease off of drugs with
therapy and Medical Aid migliera is
doing her best to stay clean but her
drug use stems from an early age I mean
at 15 I had a best friend and her mom
took a lot of Vicodin so we would steal
her pills for Assad Kmart a psychiatrist
for the empowered program says drug use
often comes with the stigma some folk
might be using substances to get a
feeling of high or Euphoria but
oftentimes that goes away and it's just
to be functioning he says drug overdose
ends up being the leading cause of death
for women who are reproductive age since
2021 650 people died from drug overdoses
in Clark County
237 were women then exposure to opioids
can lead to low birth weights right
premature births potentially some fetal
loss and if a pregnant woman was
continuing to use the baby would
potentially be going through withdrawal
symptoms after birth quintilla wimbush
has been in recovery for 12 years she's
helping other women at empowered which
she says helps her stay clean and as
long as you're breathing you have a
chance as for migliera she's taking her
recovery day by day but I'll take a
couple bad days in a lifetime of hell
you know
this program is free Friday when living
in the Las Vegas area whether you are
pregnant or postpartum Christian